it does work all right sounds good
um so uh welcome to the Richard M carp
Fletcher for today
um my name is Sandy Irani and I am the
associate director for The Institute
um all of you are probably pretty
familiar with it but I have a standard
shtick about the the Simon's Institute
founded in 2012 with the generous Grant
from the Simons Foundation we are the
world's leading venue for collaborative
research and theoretical computer
science
um before we get started just want to go
through some Logistics it's going to be
a hybrid talk so if you're in the room
feel free to raise your hand and ask a
question the mic will pick up your
question I'll be monitoring on Zoom for
questions and let me know if you want
them in real time or at the end or as we
go is is okay
um so the Richard M carp distinguished
lecture series was founded to celebrate
the contributions of the Simon's
Institute founding director Richard karp
and his many contributions to the field
of theoretical computer science
um it features distinguished scientists
um in the field related to the program
and is geared to the general scientific
audience
and is made possible by many
contributions from members of our
community
um
we're very happy today to welcome Eric
allender to be our Richard and karp
Speaker for the day so Eric has been
well known for many years as a leader in
computational complexity his work sort
of sits at the intersection between
complexity and komogoro complexity
studying how random objects are he
received his ba from University of Iowa
in 1979 and Cs and theater so we should
expect a really dramatic talk today as a
result
um hey God's PhD from Georgia Tech in
1985 and since then he's been at Rutgers
rising up through the ranks now at
distinguished Professor serving a stint
as department chair he's had numerous
leadership roles in the theater
community and Sig Act and the
computational complexity foundation and
during the 20
2009-2010 Academic Year he's a full
fellow in South Africa so his talk today
is titled how complex is complexity we
don't have the tagline for it there
anymore but what is it there it is sorry
so please join me in welcoming Eric
thanks
[Applause]
so this distinguished lecture series is
supposed to be for a more General
audience so you won't learn anything but
uh you know this is going out to uh
everybody in in Internet land and they
might want to know what all this meta
complexity is and that's what this title
is what's a metaphor so
as a goal for today I want to just give
an high level overview about what this
program this semester is and since I'm
just a few miles from Silicon Valley I
guess I need to mention that this meta
has nothing to do with any other meta
that you might uh have heard about
um
why are we having this program I'm going
to try to explain some of the reasons
for excitement and optimism in the field
and illustrate some of the topics
involved via examples and yes metaphors
and the other goal I have is I really
should apologize for that terrible pun
actually my respect for Humanity went
down a couple of notches when I did an
internet search and I found that I'm not
the first one to reach this low for uh
for that metaphor pun but um nobody
stopped me when I said that there's
optimism in the field uh
really I mean complexity theoreticians
are not known for being a particularly
optimistic group we've had that ground
out of us over the last few decades and
so
in order to present some historical
perspective about that let's um go back
to our origins in the beginning
hartmanus and Stearns created complexity
Theory
and
you know sure they got the touring award
later for that but at the time the
critical reaction was decidedly mixed
and what's the reason for this well sure
they were able to show that there were
some problems that were hard to compute
but the only things they could say
anything about were these really
artificial problems things that nobody
really wanted to compute anyway
and um
so this white noise is to illustrate the
universe of natural computational
problems at the time of hartmanus and
Stearns and the point is that yes
complexity theory was created but this
universe was still without form and void
and then cook and carp said
let there be light you know they
provided an organizing principle and you
know more precisely cook
provided it uh but people didn't
necessarily get the the message until
carp said it much more uh forcefully uh
slightly later and of course Levin also
was saying the same thing about the same
time but nobody heard that in this
hemisphere but what did they provide
they gave us this fantastic tool of
efficient reductions this organizing
principle and
what happened is that things coalesced
into these meaningful units these uh
equivalence classes things that were
basically different manifestations of
the same problem and
amazingly they corresponded to Natural
complexity classes and when you refined
the notion of reducibility you got more
and more classes of problems that are
complete for more and more complexity
classes and honestly I think the message
still hasn't gotten out to The Wider
Community to the extent that I think it
should have just how amazingly
successful this has been at making sense
of this universe of computational
problems when you know there are a few
outliers that still haven't been uh
shown to be complete for anything that
we would call a complexity class
but honestly you know if you look at the
thousands and thousands of problems that
people have considered
the overwhelming majority of them turn
out to be complete for just a handful
you know a few dozen complexity classes
I mean a few dozen doesn't fit on the
slide but it's still a pretty small
number
so
what else was happening at about the
same time
the first positive application of
complexity Theory arose namely
cryptography I mean knowing that
something was hard to compute used to be
a bad thing but now what else is it it's
great because it gives us the ability to
do something really useful so here we
are the early 70s and we've got a way to
make sense of
what had just been
a perceived difference in computational
complexity of different problems but now
there was a framework to support these
intuitions and on top of that there was
a way to make it useful in practice in
the form of cryptography so all that
needed to be done was to show that this
framework was real uh in order to enter
into this paradise and then we got a gut
punch
um Thou shalt not enter into this
Paradise by means of any tool at thy
disposal
um I mean this was actually a
three-headed Oracle Baker Gill and
Sullivan and the paradise that they're
talking about is this paradise where we
actually know something about the
complexity of problems instead of uh uh
just being conjecture and of course they
said it much more uh clearly than this
uh nonsense I wrote there namely they
gave us an oracle relative to which p is
equal to MP another relative to which p
is not equal to NP and the lesson was
that this meager toolkit of mathematical
techniques that we had were going to be
pretty much useless in attacking the big
problem and here at the left side you
see a group of complexity theoreticians
hanging their heads in despair because
they don't know what to do next but some
people did have a clever idea what to do
next
um
it doesn't really seem to make sense to
talk about attaching oracles to really
small complexity classes and so there
was some great work done on really small
circuit complexity classes ac0 the class
of things doable with constant depth
circuits of end and or gates in the
early 80s we saw great sequence of lower
bounds by first sex and sipser
Yao and hostad and uh followed very
quickly thereafter by uh
lower bounds for a richer class of
circuits uh the same class of ac0
circuits but augmented by modular
counting Gates as long as they were
counting modulo a prime by resborv and
smolensky and that was followed very
quickly by
not much
this really petered out and you know a
quarter of a century later
Ryan Williams proved this really
amazingly beautiful result that's
amazing to those of us who know just how
hard it was to get here but explaining
it to this larger audience it looks
ridiculous right I mean we've gone from
Prime p
to mod six and we proved a little bit
more than that but I don't want to give
the definition and you know here we were
talking about lower bounds for really
easy problems here we're talking about
non-deterministic exponential time and
we had to overcome a lot of barriers
just to get that far
um
so what else happened in this time
well
significantly in spite of these Oracle
results
this theory of interactive proofs was
developed which was later realized gave
us non-relativizing proof techniques
there are oracles so IP interactive
proofs was this generalization of the
normal notion of proofs that people have
been working with and the initial
intuition was yes probably pretty close
to NP
and there are oracles relative to which
co-np does not uh lie inside IP and then
there were these results in 1990
um first just giving us something
non-relativizing and then showing that
IP actually corresponded to a really
significant and much seemingly much
larger complexity class
and this was all great it led to a
fantastic development later on uh the
theory of probabilistically checkable
proofs but one thing that did not happen
was a bunch of lower bound results using
these new uh non-relativizing techniques
so what was going on well the deities
got involved with more prohibitions
um if you seek a natural way to enter
this complexity Paradise you must
forsake the one way and the one way
they're talking about is one way
functions and once again
they they said it much clearly more
clearly namely if one-way functions
exist you need a new as yet undefined
but completely unnatural approach to
prove lower bounds namely they looked at
the approaches that people have been
using to prove lower bounds thus far and
they all followed
a well they looked different but they
could be placed in this uh framework
that they called a natural approach
natural proofs and
you need something entirely different
unless one-way functions don't exist
which would be another form of hell so
um
what's relevant particularly here was
that in introducing this notion of
natural proofs they also
in some sense conceived what came to
become meta complexity
namely
most of the time people have been
thinking about computation before they
take it as input bit strings that are
graphs or
networks or
databases or something but here
they talked about doing computation
on the representation of a function just
as a bit string a a the truth table this
exponentially large object
and
after a long gestation period Then in
cabinets inside gave birth to this
modern study of complexity Theory uh by
focusing on what's known as the minimum
circuit size problem namely your input
is this bit string of length 2 to the n
which is the truth table of a function
and a number s and you just want to know
if that function has got a small circuit
a circuit of size at most s
and why is it meta complexity well let's
contrast this with complexity the
complexity question is to show that f is
hard
The Meta complexity question is to show
that
it's hard to show that f is hard
and lying behind here somehow was
perhaps the intuition that the reason
that there had been this notable lack of
progress in complexity theory for quite
a while is that
that task itself is computationally
intractable
um so
the meta-complexity question in some
sense is to show that mcsp is hard so
that it's hard to show that a problem
you know that a truth table does not
have a small circuit
what do we know about mcsp it's clearly
nnp and they showed that it's not in P
if one-way functions exist
and I need to explain what I mean here
but it's provably hard to show that this
problem is NP complete that's the usual
way that we try to show that something
is hard in complexity Theory as we show
it's NP complete or NP hard
um
but this problem is not NP complete
under the usual Notions of uh
reducibility carb producibility polytime
M reductions
unless exponential time is not equal to
zpp now this is almost certainly true
so the point of this why I'm saying it's
provably hard to show it's MP complete
is that this is something people have
been banging their heads against for
decades and we've been unable to show
that X does not have this type of
probabilistic polynomial time algorithm
and so
in contrast to the many things that have
been shown and be complete over the
years we're the only takeaway was the
problems NP complete here if you could
show its NP complete you get
you've done something else that's very
clever
the other thing that's important
historically for this is that the study
of mcsp the minimum circuit size problem
harks back to the pre-history of
computational complexity Theory
so I hit that twice okay before the
beginning
um back in 1959 in the Soviet Union
yablonsky
using different technology or different
terminology
published a theorem that he
interpreted as meaning that the minimum
circuit size problem requires
exponential time
and of course if he had done that in a
way that we agree does that then that
would solve the P versus NP question and
the thing is I mean there's a
fascinating history you can read about
it in uh in uh Lance fortnow's uh book
The the golden ticket there's a nice
chapter about this
but um yablonsky
had a lot of good intuitions focusing on
this problem was good intuition
but
um he also
historically now has been viewed as
something of a villain because of the
role he played in the development of
mathematics in the Soviet Union
uh basically uh
foreign
political pressure to bear on
mathematicians and um and komogorov was
somebody who fought against this uh in
particular uh fought against the
interpretation of uh his result is
meaning that mcsp requires exponential
time
um but relevant to this meta complexity
survey
the other thing that komogorov did was
introduce what's come to be known as
komogorov complexity and coma Gore I've
been doing fantastic work in probability
Theory had a great reputation deservedly
so
and so he understood as well as anybody
the probability Theory tells us nothing
about randomness
I mean we think of
random processes I mean that terminology
is all through komogorov complexity it
was all through probability Theory but
when we have a finite object
and we say well that's random does that
even make any sense to say that
something is random and or how much
information is in an object
uh komogorov was really the first one to
grasp well there's arguable whether or
not he was the first one because
solomonov and tayden were doing things
around the same time but certainly
uh deservedly gets credit for
understanding that this notion of
information and Randomness is really
best understood
through the lens of computation
and he gave this definition of the
complexity of X as the length of the
shortest description d
such that if you feed it into the
universal turing machine it spits out
the string X
and when a string has no short
description in other words if the
complexity is about the length of X then
that is what it means or what he defined
to mean uh that the string is Is Random
so it's a great
uh definition it leads to a beautiful
Theory but one real drawback to it is
that c is not computable which motivates
the search for computable variants and
komogorov certainly realized this too
here's this beautiful quote which is too
long for me to read
uh been a paper by Berman and Berman and
Meyer Domo
talking about the fact that already in
the 60s
motivated in part by uh komogoro's
visceral reaction against yablonski's
claims if you wanted to understand
what things were really hard to compute
well maybe looking at things like
satisfiability and highly structured
problems were the wrong thing
um instead
maybe we should focus on what we would
call nowadays the resource-bounded
komogorov random strings
now there are different ways to Define
resource-bounded komogorov random
strings and
komogorov student 11 came up with
actually a beautiful definition
this KT of X time-bounded komogorov
complexity of x
is just like komogorov complexity you've
got the length of the shortest
description and now you're adding a Time
component and what he's adding is the
log of the running time
so you want to know looking over all
descriptions take the minimum of that
sum uh the length of the description
plus log of the running time such that U
on D outputs X in time t
and this is in many ways a great
definition
but if we're trying to relate it to
Circuit complexity
there's something weird that happens
here because it captures I think what we
would agree is an odd notion of circuit
size so I'm going to have to present
some definitions
uh we're talking about circuits of and
and or Gates the usual types of
circuitry that we study and let's say
the size is the number of wires in the
circuit and the size of a function is
this the size of the smallest circuit
that computes that function we're
talking about a a finite function just a
bit string of length 2 to the n
but we're going to allow Oracle Gates
now
um
and this gives us a new measure for
every Oracle a we're talking about size
relative to a would be the size of the
smallest Oracle circuit what's an oracle
gate well here's a picture of one
it's just a box that's got wires feeding
into it and if these wires take on the
value of some string X
this box outputs a one or a zero saying
yes X is in b or no it's not
okay so that's what an oracle gate is
this again is Levin's definition I've
told you it captures an odd type of
circuit size what is that
let's let a be any language that's
complete for exponential time
time 2 to the order n
and let's let X
be a bit string encoding the complexity
of a function you know encoding the
truth table of a function
then KT of X is just the circuit size
required to compute that function but
not on ordinary circuits on these Oracle
circuits that have Oracle for this
exponential time hard problem
so
this is
the way to interpret Levin's
time-bounded komogorov complexity in
terms of circuit size which is actually
a connection but it's not on the types
of circuits we're interested in and in
case you're wondering why did Levin add
the log of the running time
um
for about 50 years we've actually known
the fastest program or a polynomial time
running time program to find satisfying
assignments for formulas if one exists
and it's just to search through
uh
bit strings in an order given by their
relative time-bounded komogorov
complexity using Levin's definition so
it's a beautiful definition and useful
for a lot of different ways but if you
aren't going to add log of the running
time well what else would you want to
add uh you know just adding the running
time would be one thing to do but then
if you're outputting a string of length
n
then every
string but have linear
complexity which would mean everything
would be random it wouldn't much look
like a komogorov complexity measure
anymore
and so the obvious thing to do is to
look at how to make the runtime
meaningfully be much smaller
and the first way to do that is to
redefine
komogorov's definition
this looks a lot like what komogorov did
except that instead of feeding the
description D into the universal machine
we're giving d and a number I and a bit
B and we're asking you
what's the eighth bit of X and if
D gives enough information to figure out
what each bit of X is well then it's a
short description and in fact
this is indistinguishable from
komogorov's original definition of
komogorov complexity and if you play the
same game with Levin's definition
then you get
something that's very close to what uh
Levin came up with
and now we just do this where we're
adding
length of the description plus the
actual running time
and we just change the little T to a
capital T and uh we get a new measure
and
this has the nice property that the
complexity of X the time-bounded
complexity of a bit string
corresponds pretty closely to the
Circuit the size of the smallest circuit
Computing that function
and
komogorov's original definition could
also be viewed essentially a circuit
size but on Oracle circuits where you've
got an oracle for the halting problem
and we've already mentioned Levin's
definition is circuit size relative to
exponential time and you can play this
game for other models of computation
there's something called branching
programs which are
away it's a circuit-like model that used
to to model space-bounded computation
and you can capture that with an
analogous definition or instead of
looking at the smallest circuit to
compute something you can ask about the
smallest formula uh and formula size can
also be captured with a definition in
this framework so
all of these meta complexity problems in
some sense are really asking about
komogorov complexity what is the length
of the shortest description in the
appropriate formalism and in particular
mcsp are canonical meta complexity
problem morally has the same complexity
as Computing Capital KT complexity and I
say morally because as yet there is
really no theorem proving that they've
got the same complexity
uh things you can prove for one you
could usually prove for the other and
actually frequently
mktp which is just mcsp where you
replace circuit size with time-bounded
komogorov complexity is easier to work
with
but it's not the only way to play this
time-bounded komogorov complexity game
um there's another one that I will
informally refer to as K poly that plays
a huge role in the current study of meta
complexity and because this is supposed
to be a general purpose talk I'm just
going to ignore the differences so
um there are important and somewhat
subtle differences but
um
what's one beautiful result about this K
poly complexity
um
I titled this the mother of all one-way
functions what is it that cryptographers
need to do when they're trying to design
uh public key crypto systems or other
crypto systems that maybe aren't even
public key well the first thing they
frequently need to do is come up with a
candidate one-way function
and
this has been an art more than a science
because their complexity theory has had
surprisingly little to say
about why some of these candidate
one-way functions ought to really be
one-way functions but here uh in this
beautiful work of view and pass from
just a few years ago they showed that
if there are any one-way functions at
all there's a way to build them from
the uh problem of computing time-bounded
komogorov complexity and this K poly
sense
so in particular
a goal of complexity Theory or a goal of
cryptographers since the 1970s had been
this hope
frequently they've given up on this hope
but in the back of their minds there's
been this hope wouldn't it be great to
be able to base cryptography on the mere
assumption that NP is hard in the worst
case
in other words showing that NP doesn't
have efficient probabilistic algorithms
so
in other words starting with the
Assumption NP not in BPP and P doesn't
have uh
efficient probabilistic algorithms you
need to
prove you'd need to be able to conclude
that this particular problem of
computing uh time-bounded komogorov
complexity also is hard in the worst
case and if it's hard in the worst case
then it's also hard and average and uh
Raphael passed in the boot camp gave
this beautiful talk
explaining this and going into much more
detail on related problems I really
recommend that to you but it's important
to note that hirahara
in 2018
proved a result that looks very much
like that second Point uh in fact he
really did show that if it's hard in the
worst case then it's hard on average but
using a somewhat different notion of
average case complexity
and so um
I
entitled this uh pass in hirahara
destroyers of Worlds what worlds am I
talking about
in poliaso he has this lovely paper
where he describes possible worlds in
which we might be living and the two
that are relevant for us here
um are pesiland
where there are problems in NP that are
hard on average but in spite of that
we still don't have any one-way
functions we don't have any cryptography
um so that's a particular form of hell
and then this other world we might live
in heuristica
might seem like a pretty good place to
live because
every problem even if NP is different
from p
uh and so things are hard in the worst
case
um everything is easy on average for any
kind of distribution that might arise in
in practice all these problems are easy
and having things be easy sounds good
except that if you would like to have
cryptography if you want to have secure
communication then this is another form
of hell and so I've shown these worlds
exploding
um because the work of pass and hirahara
in different papers and here in this
Hindu deity we see a long line of other
faces you can think of them as their
co-authors that I didn't have room to
build their uh their pictures for
um basically showing that that these
worlds are uh unlikely to exist now the
destruction has not yet complete but
honestly we've come much further in this
direction than seemed plausible just a
few short years ago and um
it's looking more and more likely that
one might actually soon be able to show
that one or the other or both of these
worlds uh
can be ruled out
um and this is just a sample of
lovely work that's been done on relating
worst case and average case using the
tools of meta complexity so let me
paraphrase a nice result of hiraharas
from 2020
the polynomial hierarchy is this class
of problems sitting right above NP and
in fact if p is equal to NP then this
whole hierarchy collapses to p
um
and there's something that's hard on
average in that hierarchy if and only if
this
particular problem
the problem of computing time-bounded
komogorov complexity
with an oracle from the polynomial
hierarchy is
hard in the worst case so this is a
particularly quotable uh crisp result
showing that a version of heuristica
doesn't happen in other words something
as hard in the worst case if and only if
uh
things are hard on average
um and like I say this is just a sample
there's a lot more that's been done in
this direction
um but there's other ground I wanted to
cover
uh metallogic and meta complexity one
big theme of the semester explores how
meta complexity provides new insight
into the field of proof complexity in
other words lower bounds on the length
required to prove that a formula is a
tautology
um but Rahul santanam will be giving a
talk uh later in the uh semester for the
carp distinguished lecture series and he
will talk on that so that's just a
forward pointer
so Raul and I have I think only one
paper together and the title of that
uses this phrase pathetic lower bound
what are we talking about there
in complexity Theory we want to separate
complexity classes which means we want
to prove super polynomial lower bounds
but our current best efforts fall far
short of this for circuits we have
really nothing super linear which I
think is pathetic by you know as hard
work that's been done to get us as far
as we've come but still uh it's a pretty
sad uh State of Affairs de Morgan
formulas are just logical formulas that
you can build with and an or Gates and
an or operators and they're the best
lower bounds we have for something uh in
NP is approximately cubic and um for
branching programs this other model of
computation I mentioned the uh the best
lower bounds we have that are
approximately quadratic
and part of the art of proving lower
bounds is just finding a problem that's
suitable for proving lower bounds and
the original cubic or quadratic bounds
that people came up with
um you know were for problems that were
specifically tailored to the task let's
show that this is a hard problem uh it
turns out that mcsp is sort of a general
purpose hard problem in the sense that
your lower bounds for mcsp on these and
some other models essentially bat match
the best that are known for any explicit
problem and there's this nice paper by
tirachi cabinets Lou and mauriziotis uh
that proves that
um
and this is
related to I mean the whole reason to to
introduce this notion of pathetic lower
bounds
is this program that arose in the study
of meta complexity for something called
magnification where you take a pathetic
lower bound and you uh use Machinery to
try to blow that up into something that
turns into a really impressive lower
bound
and in order to give a crisp example of
that let's look at us a parameterized
version of mcsp where I'm fixing the
second uh part to be some particular
size S and mcsp S is just a set of those
truth tables that have uh functions that
have circuits of size at most s
um
here's a pathetic lower bound uh tirachi
hirahara mauriziotis and Yoshida proved
that for S equal and the Epsilon
mcsp into the Epsilon
is not
you know requires essentially
quadratic time
on a model of computation that we don't
really care much about namely
probabilistic one tape Turing machines
how many people have actually programmed
one tape touring machines okay this is a
room full of complexity theoreticians
and fewer than half of you raised your
hands and there's a reason for that
is because
it takes a certain amount of courage to
say that that's a meaningful model of
computation I mean hartmanus and Stearns
deserve a lot of credit for going out on
that limb and saying you know let's
let's use this model and then they meant
to the multi-tape machine but but still
one tape Turing machines
okay you can prove a nearly quadratic
balance
why should anybody care well here's
another result by McKay Murray and
Williams
if this thing that looks like the same
problem mcsp with the size parameter end
of the B
if it's
if it requires more than time just over
linear end of the 1.01
on a one tape deterministic machine
then p is not equal to NP
now let me quote Elon Musk let this sink
in uh
we know that it's hard on a powerful
model of computation probabilistic one
tape Turing machines
and if it requires anywhere near that
much time on a one-tape even
deterministic turing machine
then you've won a million dollars you've
separated P from NP well okay it's not
really the same problem because Epson
and beta aren't the same number here but
still
this shows
that there's something
pretty impressive that can happen with
magnification you take something that
looks like a completely uninteresting
lower bound and you can
you can get something really magical out
of it and and some of these lower bounds
are things that seem like they ought to
be provable
and that's the general theme of
magnification taking modest sounding
lower bounds and you can have huge
consequences let's give another example
recall
mcsp
requires nearly cubic sized de Morgan
formulas
and this holds
also for mktp because it's kind of the
same problem as mcsd as well as for
Levin's notion of time-bounded comma
Gore of complexity because
you know unsurprisingly because this is
exp you know that's that's up there next
exponential time hard in a particular
sense
um
so here's the theorem by Oliveira pish
and santanam
if this problem requires just slightly
more than cubic size on formula size
well then you get a lovely circuit lower
bound now if you're not working in
complexity Theory showing that
exponential time requires more than
logarithmic depths might seem like a
another example of a pathetic lower
bound but trust me this would be a very
exciting lower bound we we don't know
how to prove uh
anything close to that you know even for
non-deterministic exponential time
um so
so what's your reaction likely to be
well you're thinking
that means you just can't prove
circuit lower bounds that are you know
formula size lower bounds that are more
than than cubic we don't have any
examples of of things like that so um so
maybe this doesn't seem like a very
plausible path to prove uh X not
contained in MC1 but let's give another
example
um
this is the problem of computing Levin's
complexity again for this fixed size and
the Epsilon
and
if this requires
size slightly super linear n to the 1.1
on this model that's this formulas where
you've got parity gates at the leaves
then again you can conclude exponential
time is not NC in nc1 but the amazing
thing here is that this lovely paper of
Tau does give examples of pretty easy
problems that require nearly quadratic
size on that model so
again this is even more uh a more
compelling example maybe of
a way that these meta-complexity lower
bounds combined with hardness
magnification might lead us to new
separations of complexity classes and uh
if you want to know more about this
there's a nice paper by uh Chen hirahara
Oliveira pish Raj gopal and santanam
that explains more about what can be
done with magnification as well as some
barriers to possible uh progress on that
front
so let me shift gears a little bit and
go back to something I said earlier
about mcsp and the reasons we don't know
it's NP complete uh and let me focus on
that I just put a circle around there
it's not hard for RP under car
Productions
unless X was equal to zpp
and the way to get around this is maybe
to consider
more powerful Notions of reducibility
randomized reductions so
a bppm reduction
is just
given by a deterministic polynomial time
computable function f such that if you
have a yes instance of a
then for most random bits f of x r gives
you an instance of B and X naught in a
says that for most random bits when you
can plug that in you get something
that's not in B so it's the usual notion
of M reduction except for probabilistic
uh
probabilistic generalizations
and
a lot of close relatives of mcsb have
been shown to be NP complete under these
randomized reductions including some
pretty natural examples
um a lot of the functions we want to
compute don't have a single bit of
output they've got lots of bits of
output so multi-output mcsp
was shown by elongo LOF and Oliveira to
be NP complete under these reductions uh
conditional KT complexity so the
complexity of x given y has an
additional input
um
is uh building on on a lovely result of
ilongo's uh
you can show that this problem is uh
also MP complete and a very impressive
result recently
um hirahara showed this problem mcsp
star
is also NP complete what's this this is
just like mcsp you've got the string of
length 2 to the n
some of the input some of the positions
or ones and some are zeros and then
you've got these don't care positions
that are stars
and uh
with a technical tour de force he showed
that this problem
is also NP complete under these
probabilistic reductions and there's
actually much more that he did in that
paper
and with all of this progress It's
reasonable to ask if mcsp can be far
behind or if it will be added to that
list soon
shifting gears yet again
but still talking about probabilistic
reductions
I mentioned interactive proofs
interactive proofs
as soon as they were introduced
gave rise to this notion of zero
knowledge proofs which is a way that
a prover can convince a verifier of some
fact without revealing any other
information except that single bit I
know the secret
um
and this has had
very important and widespread influence
in the theory of uh cryptography and it
gives rise to this class statistical
zero knowledge
that is
probably in NP intersect co-np but
um it's not even known to be in in NP
and there is uh a non-interactive
version of this
um that's also been studied because of
applications to cryptography where it's
an interactive proof where
the verifier and the prover can see an
input and share some random bits the
prover speaks to the verifier and then
there's no more interaction so it's a
proof that the verifier
can can work with just with the
available shared randomness
um why am I mentioning these classes
uh oh first of all let me mention that
this subclass
has got something hard in it if and only
if fzk has something hard in it so in
some sense this class nizik niszk
uh contains all the uh the computational
difficulty of statistical zero knowledge
problems
um we're going to relate that to
the canonical meta complexity problem of
computing comogorov complexity and here
we're not talking about time-bounded
comogorov complexity we're talking about
a completely
non-computable notion of complexity
where
we've got yes and no instances the yes
instances are the random strings where
let's say x has got no description of
length less than half the length of the
string and the no instances
are where there is a description so
they're very non-random that's
significantly shorter where
significantly is by this sort of
approximation error term where that term
for these results can be anything
super logarithmic and sub-polynomial
um so anything where the complexity is
too close to the length of X over 2 is
just a don't care instance
um
why are we introducing this
um oh I should mention that
for people who are real complexity
experts there's different flavors of
non-computable comma Gore of complexity
and these results fold for all the
favorite versions
foreign
decidable promise problem in other words
the yes and no instances are are
decidable at all then that problem is in
this
non-interactive statistical zero
knowledge
Pro class if and only if
it's randomly reducible to this
non-computable problem of approximating
comogorov complexity and I'm simplifying
a little bit here there's an honesty
requirement that I won't bother to
Define but
what's striking about this
is
that this is the first time that a
really well-studied and familiar
complexity class
has been characterized in terms of
efficient reducibility
to something that's not even decidable
uh and in fact it's uh an important
meta-complexity problem this komogorov
complexity problem
um
and there's a related Suite of
theorems about a space-bounded version
of non-interactive statistical zero
knowledge where the reductions instead
of being probabilistic polynomial time
or probabilistic log space or even
probabilistic nc0
everybody in this room knows about mc0
but for the wider audience these are
just circuits with every output bit just
depends on a constant number of input
bits so it's hardly any computation
happening there
so why do we care about these nc0
reductions or this log space class
um well the reason it was originally
defined is that a lot of the problems in
music the people who do care about are
in the log space class but the reason I
care about it
is because
we get
results about reducibility under
projections I'm going to Define
projections in just a bit
but anything that's in this funny nizik
L class
is reducible to this
non-decidable problem of computing
approximating comogorov complexity
via a projection and it's also
projection reducible to the KT random
strings
so
what are projections
this little trapezoid here represents a
circuit
and I'm putting the input at the top and
the output below so we're thinking of
just pouring the input at the top uh and
getting the output out at the bottom
and the reason we can think about
pouring it is that
these circuits if they're projections
have no Gates it's just wires or if you
like to think about it as Plumbing so
you've got these pipes
at the input level you've got every
input bit and its negation and then
you've got these little pipes or
strainers running through here
and at the bottom uh you know you've got
a template of some bits that are just
constant and other bits
uh you know you can duplicate bits I
guess I didn't mention that here but
every other position here that's not a
constant is just connected via a wire or
a little tube to something at the input
level
so there's really no computation
happening in these projections it's just
like a strainer
so why do we care
um
remember this problem I mentioned the
strings that are random with this KT
notion of complexity well that's easy to
see is nnp
and
you know this space-mounded class
contains a reasonable sub chunk of
polynomial time in particular it
contains non-deterministic log space as
well as some bigger classes
so
putting this all together
if NP collapses to NL
then there's a projection
that if you feed in a bunch of zeros
spits out something with high complexity
but if you just flip a whole bunch of
coins and have something with a ton of
information
it's got low complexity
so in other words
under this unlikely condition that NP is
equal to NL you get this transmutation
where you feed
hardly any information in at the top and
you get high information at the bottom
and if you feed a bunch of information
in at the top somehow it evaporates and
you get no information at the bottom
so
that seems crazy
it seems like there's no way that ought
to happen
and it even since we're talking about a
basically a an information theoretic
object it seems and and we're kind of
factoring computation out of this as
much as possible it almost seems like
you might even be able to prove that
that's possible and if you could do that
well then you've separated some
important complexity classes
so my time is nearly up
there's a lot more I could have talked
about there's been a lot of developments
I didn't mention including connections
to machine learning and probabilistic
komogorov complexity
you know here's a classic picture of
paradise
I started off by saying that there was
optimism maybe that meta complexity will
help us stand answer the long-standing
open questions in complexity Theory
is that really true well I don't want to
lie
actually I'd love to lie but
uh
maybe there's a little optimism
um you know we at least
at least it's true that recent work and
complexity and meta complexity has
already overcome a lot of apparent
barriers to
proving important results and you know
consequently we we know a lot more than
we we used to and
at the very least
complexity theory has given us some new
angles to investigate in approaching
some of these long-standing questions
and I'm definitely optimistic that
further developments in the field will
bring us further along the road to enter
this paradise of complexity and I have
come to the end
thanks
foreign
object so
uh for you could easily prove that
there's no computable function that
could do this but for H input length
it's conceivable that there could be
this little strainer this little piece
of Hardware that magically can do that
I just don't see how
and I would love
for somebody to show that it can't
possibly exist yeah and I guess my
question was even more so even for a
particular link this trainer can negate
variables I guess that's what you've got
um
the negated variables
provided the input level
because you said f of all zeros is out
of all zeros so what would that you know
this would be zero one zero one zero one
but in fact
you know you can get a lot of complexity
just by hardwiring in
some of these debts here at the output
level
and that in fact will have to happen you
can show that
but
you can't hardwire too much information
in because you've got to drop below that
threshold you know so
you have to be something really weird
happening
foreign
High complexity strength you get no
complexities
between the problem we get to the
process is just too small
right well I mean yeah we
then the paper that presents this we do
show that you can't do this if
you want uh the string here at the
output level
can the
High complexity setting to have
complexity at least four-fifths of the
length and then the low complexity
setting they have one-fifth of the
length
I think that one-fifth to four-fifths
Gap is certainly not optimal you should
be able to improve that if you can prove
it all the way to
path Plus
due to the square root log n and half
minus two to the square root login
yes
do you think there might be uh of the
contrary a barrier to these kind of
results
barriers turn up every place we we look
I haven't figured out why there would be
a barrier to this particular approach
yet
but you know the longer we stare at it
we'll probably discover that there's
yeah I can say I'm I'm not
entirely optimistic that this will work
I'm just not
completely convinced it won't
something
can you put more minutes
of course in fact there's a nice paper
by uh Rahul and I forget who
where your co-author was that
um I think Han Lin right
basically looked at
uh the sort of a Meta Meta Meta operator
to prove something
concrete about problems we care about
um
so
the short answer is yes although if you
just Define it without having a good
reason it might not be very interesting
but sometimes you can get something
interesting
let's see
thank you